foreign
welcome everybody come on in grab a seat
in this session we'll be talking about
consuming graphql apis in c-sharp thanks
so much for joining me today my name is
Brandon Minnick and
graphql is a very very special favorite
topic of mine and I'm so glad you're all
here with me because I was in a similar
seat as you just a couple years ago I
was at a con conference just like this
where I sat in the session about graphql
and immediately fell in love with it I
learned about it and found out that this
is something this is exactly what I
needed because I'm I'm a mobile app
developer I make IOS and Android apps in
c-sharp using xamarin and now.net Maui
and
as a mobile app developer one of our
goals is to make sure that we don't use
too much of your cellular data that we
don't use too much of your CPU and burn
through your battery because well that's
a that's a really good way to get a one
star review from from one of your users
and so
when I first learned about graphql and
found out that that's exactly what it's
made for it's literally made so that we
can make
less round trips back and forth from the
client to the server so that we don't
have to pull down data from the server
that we don't need and just throw it
away because with graphql we can do
everything in one round trip with
graphql we get exactly the data we ask
for no more no less and so on the client
side I love it because it makes my apps
faster it makes my my users happier
hopefully that's what gives me more
five-star reviews and then even on the
server side
if you're sending data that the client
doesn't need well now you're also
wasting bandwidth spending more money on
your cloud services so graphql actually
benefits both sides and that's what
we're going to talk about today so uh
before we get rolling I want to point
out a couple links you'll see these at
the bottom of just about every slide
today here on the bottom left that is my
Twitter handle you can find me at the
code traveler and if you have any
questions if we don't get a chance to
chat later in the conference feel free
to reach out to me I love talking
c-sharp.net graphql if you want to chat
about xamarin Maui iOS Android that's
what I'm there for feel free to reach
out anytime and then here on the bottom
right
this is a web page that I put together
just for us today just for this session
and this is where you can find all the
resources so don't worry about
memorizing anything don't worry about
having to take pictures and member
slides later because as long as you grab
this link
that's where you can find the slides
that's where you can find the open
source sample app that we're going to
play around with today the completed
version is already posted on GitHub and
I've also included a bunch of links to
learn more about graphql if you want to
continue on in this journey which I hope
we all do
so what is graphql well
quite simply it's a query language for
your API so the way graphql works is the
client
tells the server exactly what we want
and then the server gives us that
exactly back whereas with rest it's kind
of the opposite right with rest we build
a server and we say this is what the
rest endpoint is going to get back to
you so it doesn't matter if you want
five objects we're still gonna give you
all ten of them and then on our side as
client developers we just end up
throwing those away which is a shame
um so graphql kind of takes that rest
Paradigm and turns it on his head and
says why don't we let the client tell us
what they want and then we'll just give
them that data but to really understand
graphql I think it's important to know
where it came from and graphql was
actually invented back in 2012 by
Facebook and if you remember 2012 and if
you had a Facebook account you probably
downloaded the Facebook app uh this was
right around the time they released
their first Native app and when it first
came out
it was really bad uh they got tons and
tons of one and two star reviews because
users were complaining that the app was
using too much of their cellular data
that the app would get really hot when
they used it because it was really
churning through the processor it was
using too much memory and when you think
about it it makes a lot of sense because
if we look here this is just a
screenshot from my Facebook app but look
at all the data that this app loads just
when you launch it like I didn't do
anything I just opened the app and all
of a sudden I'm greeted with all this
multimedia with videos with images I
have a whole timeline for status updates
from my friends and their profile
pictures their names the date and time
they posted it and it's not just your
timeline that loads
the notifications tab also loads so you
get in all your notification data about
uh upcoming events mutual friends people
you may know and their profile pictures
and our mutual friends count and so
if you think about this in terms of
retrieving data from a rest API
it ends up looking something like this
where when the app first launches it
already knows who I am so it can call
facebook.com user slash ID and get the
information about me so it can get my
updated profile picture maybe I updated
my my likes and dislikes on my profile
whatever it'll grab all that and then
once it has that information it's going
to make a couple more API requests
because once it knows about me and who I
am and that I'm confirms I'm
authenticated then it can go find my uh
upcoming events it can go find my
friend's birthdays it can go find mutual
friends but even once those responses
come back it's Gotta make another round
trip to go get more information because
for like mutual friends okay now it
knows the IDS of my mutual friends but
it's got to do another round trip to go
get their profile picture uh their name
and so what we end up seeing or what
Facebook ended up seeing back in the day
was this Cascade did API calls where we
would start with one that when that
comes back it would trigger multiple
more when those would come back they
would trigger multiple more and they
were seeing dozens upwards of hundreds
of API requests being made as soon as
the user launches the app so it was
pretty easy to figure out why those bad
reviews were flowed in because sure
they're using a lot of data all these
round trips they're waiting on the
previous one so you know data can only
travel so fast literally limited by the
speed of light and the location of where
you are and where the server is so if
the server happened to be on the other
side of the world and it takes 600
milliseconds to get there and back well
we gotta wait 600 milliseconds before we
can make that next API request and then
wait another 600 milliseconds before the
next API request and so you can really
start to see how the load times could be
slow the cellular data usage can be high
and so the the engineers at Facebook
said there's got to be a better way
and that's when they came up with the
idea for graphql where they took all of
those rest apis and consolidate them
down into one graphql API
now quick caveat just in case anybody
out there is a little uneasy that we're
talking about graphql and we're talking
about Facebook yes Facebook invented it
but they no longer own it Facebook has
essentially donated the technology to
the global good to developers like us
there's a whole graphql Foundation that
now exists the graphql foundation is
what owns the graphql Technologies they
have a steering committee with people
from all over the world who are
constantly updating and creating new
graphql specs every year
so if you're not a fan of Facebook
that's okay yes they invented it but now
it's safe and sound in the graphql
foundation similar to how we have things
like dot net foundations that handle
open source libraries the graphql
foundation also manages all of the open
source graphql libraries so
so right they shrunk all those rest apis
down to this one API endpoint
and you might be thinking well wait a
minute
if there's only one API endpoint
how how does it know what data to give
back because you know I'm sure Facebook
has gigabytes of data just on me let
alone all of us and we can't possibly
send all that back in one request well
the way this works is when we hit this
API endpoint as a client as a mobile app
as a website as a desktop app what we do
is we provide a query so in our graphql
query we tell the server exactly what we
want
so for example in this query here I'm
telling the server I want to get
information about a user and so I've
specified a specific user and then I say
for that user give me their name
their upcoming events count
and give me some friend suggestions but
actually just one just the first one and
for that friend's suggestion give me
that person's name and our mutual
friends count
and then what comes back from the server
is this Json response now this is the
same Json we know and love so if you
know how to deserialize Json you already
know how to handle a response from a
graphql server it's the same thing we
would deserialize this using something
like system.text.json now we can use it
in our c-sharp code Happy Days
and if we look at that Json response
it's exactly the data we asked for so
there's the user the name Brandon
Minnick that's me I have looks like I
have four upcoming events count
and it gave me one friend suggestion
just like I asked for it it looks like
it's recommending uh my friend Seth
Juarez and we have 18 friends in common
so this is really cool because again
most of us probably already know how to
handle this Json response but if we look
at this query
this query is not Json at first glance
it kind of looks like Json right but if
you squint a little bit you'll notice
there's no there's no colons there's no
double dots uh there's no quotes and
that's because this
this is the graphql this is this is the
query part of the query language and so
you might be thinking well okay great
like I came in here to learn about a new
cool tool called graphql and now this
guy's telling me I gotta learn a whole
new language well I'm out but don't
worry it's actually super super easy to
figure out how to form these queries
I've been using graphql for years and to
be honest with you I've I still have yet
to memorize it so let's show you how to
do it using the GitHub graphql API
so let's jump out here and I've gone to
the GitHub graphql API and when you
navigate there you're greeted with this
GUI in our browser and this is pretty
cool this is something called graphical
which I think is a fantastic name
because it's a graphical user interface
for your graphql back end so Kudos
whoever came up with with this name
and here is where we can figure out how
to write queries for in this case
github's graphql API endpoint now what's
really cool with guise like these you
get stuff like this for free when you
build your graphql server so every every
tool every SDK that's out there at least
as far as I know of definitely in
the.net world
we all get this for free so I build my
graphql server and it just comes
included and
one of the coolest things about these is
this docs tab here
so the way graphql works is we when we
create a graphql server we Define what's
called a graphql schema and that schema
essentially
is
it lists all the objects it lists all
the queries the methods that any user
can provide and because we've
pre-defined that
these tools these guis like graphical
when you load them they can crawl the
schema and provide you the current
latest up-to-date documentation and so
this is really cool because it means
graphql's
self-documenting we don't have to write
any docs because all the latest greatest
docs are already here for us now I think
GitHub still does write some docs and
it's not a bad idea right to help your
users out but
do you have to not really because check
this out so
here in the documentation Explorer
we're greeted with two root types these
are the same
root types that you'll see on every
graphql server the first one is query
query is like a get request query says I
want to get information back from the
server but I'm not going to change
anything so I'm just going to make a
query you're going to send me data Happy
Days
a mutation does make changes on the
server so mutations kind of like our
puts our posts our updates our deletes
our patches anything anytime we want to
change something on the surfer that's
going to be a mutation now for us today
I'm this is actually live I'm logged
into GitHub you have to log in to use
this so we're just going to stick to
queries because
I don't want to ruin anything on my
GitHub account by accident but the way
this works now is on the left here all I
have to do is copy this value in
and then on the right
I can click this so this is the object
that comes back when I make a query
and when we drill down into it now we
can see all of the other objects that we
can query for and if you're familiar
with GitHub then a lot of this probably
looks familiar like we can query for
organizations we could query for
repositories we can ask about security
all this fun stuff so why don't we do
let's do a query for this user here
uh and before I copy it
let's talk about this because again this
is telling us that when I query for a
user it's going to bring back a user
object
um but this one looks a little different
this says to query for a user I need to
provide a login and that login needs to
be a strict and now in the graphql world
this exclamation point means that string
cannot be null so I need to pass in a
non-nullable string which if you think
about it makes sense right because how
do I query for a user if I don't tell
you what user I want a query for so
again I'm just going to copy this
paste this over here
and actually you can already start to
see you actually get intellisense
let's bring that back up auto complete
and everything there we go so if we type
in user
login and I'll put in my GitHub username
which again kind of weird right that
they use the word login like it's not
asking for your password it's just
asking for your GitHub username but
whatever GitHub you guys can do whatever
you want so now that we have that we can
drill deeper so I can click on this user
object again
and start discovering What fields can I
get back about a user and so I see
things here on the right like uh I see
bio uh Avatar URL what else do we want
to query for maybe
we could search for company
we could do followers see how many
people are watching our
our GitHub accounts and now we have a
query and I don't know if you noticed
but along with intellisense it'll even
tell you
if you forget something so see how we
got a little red squiggle here if I go
to execute this right now it's going to
yell at me because
it tried to warn me but I didn't listen
so let's actually finish this query
run it
and there we go this is
this is the Json response and again it's
exactly the data that we asked for so
there's my bio the URL for my avatar the
company I work at the total followers I
have and if we decide later on that you
know in our app the designer came along
and said ah we don't really care about
things like the user's company anymore
well we just remove that from our query
and now
that company information is gone so
again with graphql we get all of this
information in one round trip we don't
have to wait for this response to come
back before then we can follow up like
we have to do with rest to make another
request for say the follower count we
get it all back at once and we get
exactly the data we need because it's
exactly the data we ask for so we don't
have to worry about using too much
bandwidth or paying extra in server
costs because the server is always
giving 10 objects when we only need one
now
this is pretty cool right but what are
we really doing we're not we're not
writing code here we're we're in the
browser the browser's running on GitHub
servers like we're not even sending this
query from here in Oslo on my computer
so I want to show you how this is
actually working and to do that I'm
going to bring up Postman here
and let's
hide some of the the details from test
runs so what I've done I've entered in
github's graphql API endpoint here
and I've told Postman that I want to
make a post request now
wait a minute post isn't that a rest API
thing well it turns out every graphql
request is just a post request so if
you've ever made a post request in
c-sharp you already know how to make a
graphql or a HTTP client request to a
graphql endpoint you just create your
HTTP client you say post async and we
get the data back so
pretty cool but what do we put in the
body here so it's a post request which
means we're going to have something in
our body and it turns out we have one
field that we enter in that one field is
query
and then for the value of that
we just come back here
copy this and paste it in
so
what I'm going to do now is just let me
get some rid of that uh White space
because otherwise Postman gets mad at me
there we go nope one more
and I'm gonna make sure we keep the
quotes here and there we are so so I put
in
the exact query that we just essentially
copy pasted in graphql I just copy paste
that here and when I click Send
we get exactly the data back that we
asked for so
so right so under the hood graphql is
just using post requests we can use C
sharp HTTP client send post async copy
paste those graphql queries into the
body and we're good to go and just like
we saw uh back in the browser if if
maybe I don't care about the Avatar URL
anymore I just delete that from my query
and now it's gone
pretty cool
okay so let's do a quick review on
graphql
graphql apis have one endpoint so every
graphql request you make whether you're
going to do a query a mutation changing
something on the server at or not you're
going to hit the same endpoint
um if you want to you can have multiple
graphql endpoints at your company some
companies do that for say like a public
facing graphql API and an internal
graphql API that's totally cool but you
don't have to everything can go through
the same endpoint
graphql apis are self-documenting so
just like we saw in graphical
anytime we navigate to a graphql server
in our browser
we're presented with this GUI that'll
have all of the docs there and those
docs as soon as we load that website in
the browser
those docs are generated so they're
always up to date they're always showing
you exactly what's running on the server
at that time
graphql requests are just post requests
so graphql leverages the post HTTP
method under the hood and again if you
know how to make a post request using
HTTP client then you already know how to
make a graphql request as well
just remember that the graphql request
body
is going to be one field for your Json
that's called query and then on the
other side for the value just copy paste
in exactly what we found using the
browser
and like we mentioned that response is
just Json so it's the same Json we know
and love deserialize it and now we have
C sharp to play around with in our code
all right well speaking of code let's
actually write some so
there are two popular graphql client
sdks for net the first one being
graphql.client this is kind of the this
is the OG this was the first graphql
client that was created 4.net developers
it's the oldest and not surprisingly it
also has the most downloads on nougat
but the one we're going to focus on
today is strawberry shake uh strawberry
shakes
newer it's uh we'll say relatively new
it's been around for about two years
um and I'll I'll tell you I've used both
of these I've I have built apps that
have used graphql client I've built apps
that use strawberry shake and strawberry
shake is incredible the big difference
between these two
well I guess there's a couple big
differences but the main one that I
really appreciate is strawberry shake
writes the code for us it includes a lot
of source generators a ton of source
generators and whereas with graphql
client I end up having to write all that
code myself so not that that's a bad
thing you know graphql.client the SDK is
solid it's stable it's been around for
forever uh if you use it great but with
strawberry shake can't recommend it
enough we'll see all the code that it
generates for us in just a second but
it's also the fastest client
um they have benchmarks posted on the
website I've shared links to the website
on uh on the URL that I've provided here
where they do benchmarks and the
creators of strawberry shake have
literally created the fastest graphql
client and the fastest graphql server
sdks in the world so literally it
doesn't matter if you're coding in
Python go rust
they go head-to-head against all of them
and blow them all out of the water in
terms of requests per second uh memory
allocation speed and response and it's
kind of cool because they're all
strawberry shakes totally open source so
you can go see how they did it and if
you've ever want to be if you ever want
to be terrified go look at it because
it's nothing but pointers and refs and
you know all the unsafe code that we're
told not to do but luckily they're
they're a lot smarter than me so they
they know how to do it and then they
have a boatload of unit tests to make
sure everything's good and everything's
solid which totally is so so let's check
this out I'm going to
jump over here to visual studio
and I have an app that I built
and this app
let's bring it up there we go so made
this in.net Maui and right now I've got
an empty books page so nothing appears
on this page because well
we're going to write that code together
but before we write the code for the
client side let me show you a little
around the server side because both of
those are in here so I have a
hot chocolate graphql.mobile and hot
chocolate.graphql.back end and you might
be wondering well wait a minute hot
chocolate I thought we were talking
about strawberry shake well it's the
same company uh the company is called
chili cream they're back-end sdks called
hot chocolate and their front end SDK is
called strawberry shake so
I don't know I guess they get really
thirsty sometimes and
that's how they come up with their names
but yeah we have strawberry shake dot
Maui in our client side and our mobile
app because again this is a.net Maui app
they also make strawberry shake dot
Blazer if you want to use it for your
Blazer app or if you just want to use it
in a console app they also have just
strawberryshake.core which you can use
so lots of options there but right so on
the server side hot chocolate
so how does this work well
here's my program
program.cs file
that's it
how many lines of code is that 11
including the using namespace up here
um literally we just say
builder.services.ad graphql server so
this is an extension method that hot
chocolate provides for us and once you
say that it's gonna
basically do most of the work
and then all I had to do was provide it
with a custom query type so what does
this look like well this query
this is just a c-sharp class you'll
notice it doesn't inherit from anything
it doesn't Implement any interfaces this
is just something I wrote and what this
is is three methods one's called get
books which returns an innumerable of
type book we have another one called get
book so one book where if we provide the
title
the graphql API will provide the first
book it finds matching that title or we
can search for the author using git
author same idea we search via the
author's name we get the author's
details back and you know this is this
is just a sample app something I made so
I could share it with you today and so
all this data is just hard coded
but here
in this query this is where you would
actually point to your data source so
these methods in the graphql world these
are called resolvers
and these resolvers point to wherever
your data lives so if your data is in a
database this would go fetch the data
from the database or what's really
common nowadays because most companies
have
already built a whole Suite of rest apis
is you can put a graphql server in front
of those rest apis and then you can have
these graphql resolvers point to your
existing rest apis because you know
those rest apis have been around forever
you know the company has some sure spent
a lot of money and investment in them
and don't want to lose them because if
you got rid of your rest apis it will
probably break all your apps but if you
want to take advantage of graphql going
forward you can point these methods to
those existing rest apis and leverage
all that existing technology you have
that you know works and it's tested and
trusted and that's kind of been the
really common approach for a lot of
companies starting out but yeah if
you're building a Greenfield app you can
just point directly to your database
Happy Days
so
I have this running
so in my browser I'm going to navigate
to my local host here so I'm just on
localhost Port 5100 slash graphql
and again we get a cool little GUI here
so it looks a little different from
graphical the one that is running on
github's graphql API but if I'm being
honest this one's a little cooler
because check out
yeah
so again this is made by the company
chili cream who makes hot chocolate for
the server they make strawberry shake
for the client and this
is named banana cake Bop so
hope you're hungry try to keep up but
yeah if we go look over here right we
can see the schema reference this is the
one that I built the one we were just
looking at in code and again feels very
similar to what we're just looking at on
the GitHub API where I have a query
and in that query we can call for
we can query for books which returns all
the books and in graphql terminology
these square brackets denote a list so
anytime you see those square brackets
around it means this is a list of type
book and again that exclamation point
means the list is not nullable so we'll
never return null but also the list will
never contain a null book either so a
non-nullable book
in a non-nullable list is what we're
going to get back and again this was all
auto generated for me I didn't I didn't
do anything other than
write this code right here I promise all
I did was write this code and then hot
chocolate
automatically inferred it for us and
they do they do some fancy things too
like you can see I named
let's see how we can get these side by
side maybe whoa all right so like I
named this method get books
but when hot chocolate generated the API
for me they changed it to just books to
kind of better follow best practices in
graphql which I appreciate
um and again if if I had told it that
the book was nullable then you as you
can imagine this exclamation point would
go away and it would Auto generate the
API with the possibility of a no book
coming back but you know you can see
that this is the one I made because I
gave it a description called return all
books and we see down here this returns
all books so it literally took this code
just because
I passed it in here and said this is my
query type and then auto-generated all
this stuff for us so again
I've I've never memorized how to do
graphql queries I've never made one on
the fly without coming here so if we
keep following that pattern we can make
a query
and we can use the intellisense here to
say I'm going to ask for all the books
and for each book I want to know its
title I want to know it's author and
give me that author's name and birthday
and when I click run
just like we expect we get all of the
books back from our API
really really cool
so how do we do this on the client side
well
or how do we consume it on the client
side it's probably a better way of
putting that
so let's actually dig into some code
here so as we've already pointed out I
added this nuget package ahead of time
strawberry shake dot Maui and again if
you're doing Blazer they have strawberry
shake top Blazer there's also strawberry
shake dot core if you just want the core
functionality and you don't care about
the platform they got options for you
and when you add this to your app
there's a couple steps you have to do
and
I'll show you those command line
commands that I did ahead of time but
when you run this command line command
to initialize strawberry shake it
generates this Json file
and this Json file has a couple things
in it that are pretty cool so first of
all I pointed strawberry shake to my
graphql API endpoint and so when I
initialized strawberry shake what it
does this is just a one-time thing it
goes out to your graphql API and it
pulls down the schema so the same schema
that I didn't write because I made I use
hot chocolate to write my code in C
Sharp hot chocolate generated that
schema automatically for me
strawberry shakes pulling down that
schema and it saves it here locally so
if we scroll down there's another file
called schema.graphql
and this is the schema that hot
chocolate on the server side had Auto
generated for us and you can see like
this is exactly what we expect right
like we have our book query we have the
books query that returns all the books
and that's the list of books with the
exclamation points meaning it's not
nullable we have the type of book and
every book is going to have a title
which is a string that's not null and an
author that's not null and every author
is going to have a name and a birthday
so so right away strawberry shake knows
everything about our graphql API and
this is what it uses
to Auto generate all the c-sharp code
and
if we dig in a little bit not sure how
much everybody's played with Source
generators
they're
if I'm being honest they're pretty
difficult to figure out uh once you get
them working though they're really cool
really fun to play with but
check this out so I went into I went
into the Ops folder here for my mobile
app
and if we dig into it
eventually we'll come across a folder
called Berry and that's where strawberry
shake stores all its auto-generated code
so if we wanted to
I could open up this file
and we can see all the code that it
created for us and and this is tons of
code so things like a class called get
books query result there's information
in here for how it instantiates its
version of HTTP client and you know
we're not going to go through this but
look at that it generated almost a
thousand lines of code for us whereas if
we weren't using strawberry shake we
would have to write all this code
ourselves so again this is why I love
using strawberry shake highly highly
recommend it because not only do we all
get get this code for free but it's also
the fastest SDK available to.net
developers and actually any any graphql
developers out there
so
right
now we have
our initialization file
I ran a command line command that I'll
show you in a bit to initialize it it
got the schema for us so now it knows
exactly how the type system and
everything on our graphql server works
and what do we do next well
in.net Maui it uses the same
initialization Paradigm that we use
across.net so if you're a Blazer
developer or asp.net core developer I'll
guarantee you've seen the
builder.services Paradigm where we have
an iservice collection that we can add
transients Singleton scoped variables
too well
with strawberry shake they gave me this
method
add Library graphql client and that
method is named that
because I told it to so back in that
configuration file you'll see
I said name this thing Library graphql
client and then anytime you generate
code generate it in my namespace hot
chocolate graphql.mobile
so it went ahead and did just that
thanks strawberry shake and then just
like anytime we're adding HTTP client to
our dependency injection container we
can configure it so I gave it the Base
address so it's just pointing here to
localhost on my machine and then we can
configure the message handlers I added
some rules about error policies so it'll
automatically retry if it can't find the
server and then we won't go this deep
into graphql today but it also supports
websockets so another part of graphql
along with queries which again that's
reading data from the server mutations
which changes data on the server
graph graphql servers also have
something called a subscription and
it's kind of exactly what it sounds like
it allows us to subscribe to events on
the graphql server so I can subscribe
and say hey let me know anytime
um
this repository changes right let me
know anytime a user commits code so that
I can update in real time on my app and
we can subscribe to graphql servers it
uses iobservables and we can just sit
there and watch them and all this
real-time data just Flows In which is
really really cool but for today we'll
just be sticking we'll stick into the
basics stick to queries so we've added
our graphql client here to our services
or our I service collection
and so now
I can go into my books view model and I
can start writing some code because I've
already written this I have this uh this
is a the command that runs when the app
launches called refresh books and right
now it's just totally empty so that's
why we don't have any data visible on
our mobile app but
What I've Done ahead of time is I've
added in that Library graphql client
that strawberry shake generated
automatically for us and
what we do
we can say VAR result
equals client
dot get booksquery
dot execute async and then I pass in my
cancellation token
that's it
we've just gotten data back from our
graphql server it's automatically
deserialized for us and we can do it
everywhere with it so
what do we write just a couple lines of
c-sharp code including some
initialization and we're off and running
and so what we'd want to do is something
like
um just like we do with HTTP client
right we want to make sure there's no
errors this will
throw uh automatically throw a
graphql exception if I remember
something like that it'll throw an
exception if any errors are found so if
it couldn't connect to the server it'll
throw an exception or you know if you
misform your graphql query like if I ask
for something that doesn't exist well
this is going to yell at me but you can
see here
I still get an error back so either I
can't access it or maybe I'm not allowed
to access it based on permissions
whatever it might be that'll rethrow any
exceptions but
now that we know that the data doesn't
have any exceptions we can just double
check that none of that data is null
and once we know it's not null
we'll just iterate over it so we'll say
for each book in result.data.books
add it to this observable collection
that I've already initialized up here so
I'll just say books dot add
book
and there we go and so now when we run
the app
let's see what happens
all right so now we have all the data
showing in our app super fast granted
the round trip time is probably about a
millisecond but
super super easy right we just had to
write a couple lines of c-sharp code we
just had to add it to our I service
collection and strawberry shake
basically did all of that for us so
now I want to show you what if we want
to make a different query right like we
created this get books query by adding
this file here so this file
is called getbooksquery.graphql
and if we look back at the configuration
for this graphql Json file
it knows to search for any any folder
any any file in any folder with the dot
graphql file name and use that to create
what we're asking you to so whether it's
a query whether it's a mutation look for
these dot graphql dot graphql files and
auto generate the code for me so why
don't we why don't we create another one
here on the Fly
and let's do one called uh how about we
do git book by title
now
what I'm going to do is because
if we're going to query for a book by a
title then we need to know what title
we're querying for and that means we
need to pass in a variable and the way
that works here in graphql is to name
the variable here so I'll name it title
and I'll let graphql know that this is a
non-nullable string
and then down here we'll just use
intellisense again to say I want a book
and then book needs to know
the title so I'll give it that variable
title
and then again I want to know give me
the book's title give me the books
author give me the author's name give me
their birthday
and the only thing left to do
is to pass in that variable and we do
that down here you can actually see I'm
getting yelled at there's a little
squiggle right down here where it says
variables and so for every variable that
we add into our graphql query we can
easily add it down here so I can say
there's going to be a variable title and
hopefully I spelled that correctly let's
see if this runs boom and look at that
we get one book back from our graphql
API it's exactly the book we asked for C
sharp in depth and now we've got another
brand new graphql query that just like
we've been doing all day right copy
and we're going to paste it in
what's it called get book by title so
get book by title Dot graphql
and I'm just going to paste that in
again I'm not memorizing anything about
graphql or the server and once I build
this now
hot chocolate's off and running so hot
chocolate is now generating all the code
behind this
um you know when we first saw that auto
generated file it was what like 780
lines of code so let's see if we jump
back in there
go back to Barry open this up
how we doing now oh look at that
we're up to 1200 lines of code 1200
lines of code we didn't have to write
that's so cool and if we go back to our
view model
now
we can use it so I can say
um let's see
this is the John's Key result he's the
author of C sharp in depth and just like
we did above I'll just say client
now
check that out I've got get book by
title again totally auto-generated for
me I didn't have to write anything other
than you know copy and paste into
graphql query and
again
execute async now
remember we created that variable title
well guess what execute async says hey I
need to know the title so no problem
I'll pass in C sharp in depth again
and of course give it our cancellation
token like we always do as good
developers and you know what we've
already got that book displayed in the
app so I'll tell you what let's put a
break point here
run the app again
because we don't really need to add it
to the screen twice you know I love John
skeet but
we don't need to show his book twice in
the library but this break point boom
already done
um
and we can see the result here so let's
see if we dig into the result
there we go we've got our data and look
at that there's our our book object
and our book all right C sharp in depth
and we can get information about the
author here and look at that there's
John skeed and you know I don't know his
birthday so I just
basically made it January 1st but uh but
yeah so with again just not even not
even writing any code strawberry shakes
generating this all for us
all I have to do now is just say execute
async pass in my variable name and we're
off and running so couldn't recommend
strawberry shake more I actually have I
have a couple apps in the App Store and
one of them I can't wait to implement
strawberry shaking because I didn't even
use the other Library I didn't even use
uh graphql.client in it I actually wrote
everything by hand so I can't wait for
the pull requests when I open that up
because it's going to remove
thousands of lines of code probably 10
000 lines of code just gone code I don't
have to maintain anymore it's gonna be
great
okay
so we've got a little bit of time left
so let's see
I want to show you
those initialization steps because yeah
I mean I totally skipped them but wasn't
sure how much time we'd have wanted to
make sure we saw all the cool stuff but
these
are the docks
so they've got getting started docs for
Blazer xamarin console apps uh he hasn't
added Maui yet Maui's still in preview
I've actually been working with this guy
Michael stabe you might see him around
he's given some talks he's the really
smart guy that writes all these Source
generators that knows how to do all the
pass by reference and unsafe code so if
you ever want to meet a really really
smart guy look out for Michael stab or
go see his talks he'll be around
and
and so what we do to initialize
strawberry shake we have to bring in its
tool manifest so we pop open the command
line we say.net new tool manifest and
then we tell it to install the
strawberry shake tools
and then once those tools are installed
I'm going to skip these steps because
these are just how to initialize the
project how to add the nuget packages
here we go so this is the good stuff
down here
so this
dot net graphql init
this is what auto-generated that
graphql.json file whoops zoom out
this one right here so this file
was auto-generated for me after I ran
.net graphql init
and when I do that I point it to or I'd
rather I pointed it to my graphql server
so when I ran this I said.net graphql
the knit and then I pointed to localhost
Port 5100 graphql
and that's when it went out and it
fetched my graphql schema that
ironically
it also had generated for me on the
server and then again
this graphql schema is how
or how strawberries Shake knows how to
auto generate all the c-sharp for us so
incredibly incredibly powerful tool and
also just happens to be
the most performant most memory
efficient and the fastest on the market
so can't recommend it enough
strawberry shake so let's do uh just a
quick review because again I know I
skipped over these steps I want to
really make sure we point this out we do
have to install the strawberry shake
tools so again that means opening up the
terminal typing in net new tool manifest
into your folder so the folder where you
have the project then running.net tool
install strawberry shake dot tools
and then we want to Auto initialize that
schema so telling strawberry shake hey
go get my schema so that you can do all
the work for me and generate all the
c-sharp code for me and we do that by
saying.net graphql init
passing in the URL of our graphql API
and then after that like we saw we we
can add it to our iservice collection if
we're using dependency injection which
hopefully we are I think at least that's
my favorite way of doing everything but
really after that all we're doing is
we're just adding these dot graphql
files so you can put a dot graphql file
anywhere in your project and strawberry
shake will start searching your project
every time you build if it finds a new
one it'll generate all the c-sharp code
that goes with it and then when we go
back to our code or when we go to write
our code
all we do is say client dot whatever the
query's name is dot execute async
and we're done
all right
well if you haven't had a chance yet
here is the link to all of the resources
today so make sure to take out your
phone grab a picture of this you can
share it with your friends share it with
your colleagues who maybe couldn't make
it today because this is where you can
find the slides this is where you can
find a link to the GitHub repo where we
have the completed sample that we just
built together today and I've also
included a lot of resources that I used
when I was first learning about graphql
that I know will be helpful for you too
as well
thank you
[Applause]